hey guys welcome to frenemies episode
number two if you're seeing this
intro it means our original one got cut
because it was way too
graphic it was way too graphic right
away but hopefully that one's still in
but if not
it was super funny and you all missed
out big time you'll miss out so instead
we'll just talk about what no we were
just talking about drugs like right off
the bat
well i can say drugs i just don't give
explicit
explanation we're just talking about
yeah we should just talk about food or
something because that's like more
what did you eat this weekend you
started the last podcast off with what i
would you eat
fatty you said that last podcast oh yes
because
breakfast that's true i did say that
what'd you have for breakfast i don't
eat i'm telling you i'm not eating right
now
well okay let's say weekends and not
during the week have you lost weight
not really and moses knows i skipped
dinner i've been skipping dinner dude
i've seen you and moses have been eating
some
absolute trash bro don't even act like
you don't eat you guys are eating
in the i really haven't eaten any dinner
you can ask them i don't eat dinner and
it's been really awful and i feel like i
still haven't lost anyway because i have
a shoe i have a music video shoot
covered safe i have a music video who
cares if you're fat in your music video
no because i'm in like lingerie and
stuff well you're fat
yeah that's what i mean just embrace
what it is you are
fat i don't have trouble breathing can
you bend down and tie your shoes
yeah okay let me see you prove it right
now can you you prove it right yeah can
you
no prove it i'll do it if you do it bend
down no bend
down oh
did you hear him pick up that audio it
was it was hard for you
you did something
well i don't want i don't want everyone
to see your all your [ __ ]
yeah okay so what are we talking about
good you can lean down you can tie your
shoes congratulations
can you see your penis over your belly
in the shower can we talk about that
yeah
yes i can if i lean
[Laughter]
looking straight down can you see it let
me think
yeah i mean yeah i just probably yeah
and how big is it it's fine it's fine
less than five no four
no it's bigger than four and five
do you measure i have when i was younger
i haven't measured it recently some
people have you had sex within your life
ten actually yeah how about you
of 10 billion i mean no i have a lot i
can't even know i don't even know i'd
never have counted but that's exciting
i'm happy for you i literally thought
you were like a virgin
when you met you i have a kid i popped a
xanax before this once i feel like i'll
be better this episode i was a little
you did i did you were too stressed
how much do you take like a full zany
bar or i'll take wait what's this any
bar
oh you don't oh okay well let's just get
right into it
oh it's like you don't know what a zany
bar is that was like when i was in
college the super popular
it's like a full bar i'm new to zanz
only the past few years has been
a fast few years that's not new
well i'm not like high school as a next
person i was like clean in high school
but no i don't i don't take i don't take
xanax but how long do
or i mean it helps you yeah i took one
like halfway through rosh hashanah
dinner
and i was like don't do you took one of
you were so stressed at my house you
took it
i gotta warn you those are really
dangerous i'm just gonna tell you i
don't know if you know
overdose on february 5th of 2018. that's
not a mental hospital
oh that's why i see and the whole bottle
like i took like a whole bottle of xanax
why they put my stomach it was yeah
wait were you trying to no but they
thought i was so i got 51.50
well why why would you take a whole
bottle then we didn't do an intro but
um oh i was just depressed i just got
broken up with literally that day and i
was just like i need to like cope with
it because i'm supposed to go to a party
that are you sure you weren't trying to
kill yourself because that sounds like
attempted too
i wasn't i swear i really am not
suicidal i'm like way too like
narcissistic for that i think
but i'm not yeah anyways for me xanax
just makes me sleepy
it doesn't really do anything for me i
definitely i've tried it for my anxiety
and i just go
faster
it's the same thing yeah volume volume's
a little stronger
welcome everybody that's it we're making
it through frenemies with the help of
xanax and benzos i don't usually take
one fyi for the record when i first like
the earlier this year i was and now i
just i just look like i i just took a
one because i
every time i come here it's very awkward
and uncomfortable it's not it's
so uncomfortable friday was so
uncomfortable last monday was uncle
everything's uncomfortable
do you have um anxiety problems no not
at all
so what do you take ex xanax for two
years um
that's more like just i think i is it
anxiety it's more
i'm not anxiety i think i'm more just
like in my own head
so like when i'm around like people i'm
just like oh this is awful
you're always like this is awful yeah
are you feeling that right now
um no because you're good that's why we
were chatty before but you don't want to
chat with me i was talking to ethan he's
like just talk about the podcast like
why can't we talk just talk right now
as friends dude we did
we talked everything okay let's just
let's
let's get let's pull together vietnam
vietnam
communist country didn't know that what
what are you talking about it's a
communist country
well like what well no right now
currently in the communist country they
all have to just go by what the rules
are there's no democracy
what jack check that's not true dan the
current day vietnam is not a communist
country
yes it is oh it is the girls what am i
talking about
you learned that from your nail people
yeah hang on hang on hang on
all right anyways we can go to the next
one next topic here's the here's the
thing
that i want to talk about okay you came
over to my house
on friday to celebrate the jewish new
year
with my family i was expecting
basically it wasn't what i expected i'll
tell you
you were very calm you were not like i
was expecting you to like kick down the
door and be
the center of attention and [ __ ] but you
were very chill
and and and and uh fine but the one
thing that i found funny
was that you showed up in like an idf
uniform and a beret
and [ __ ] like you know it you know that
we don't dress like that
yeah cause you're the american jews i
was representing the israeli jews that
were present
there was two israelis there neither of
them were an idf uniform they
were though at one point i was
representing us i was like on their side
i was the israeli hawkman side
and you were representing american
client side so i was trying to you know
show up moses thought i looked cute by
the way he said i looked very good
he's out of his [ __ ] mind you can't
walk around and that
okay what did you think of my family i'm
gonna i have i have a what i want to get
into later
is that trisha has been making really
obscene
borderline i would i don't want to say
anti-semitic because you love jews
wait what me i'm not and i said i'm not
gonna say anti-semitic i love jews
we always talk about this yeah but it
goes to a point of like
fetishizing that true yeah so i don't
know if that's anti-semitic or
why can't people fetishize i'm sure
people fetishize you
well you can finish as a person but not
like a group of people no like chubby
people are fetishized like i'm
fetishized because i eat
that's a fetish like you can fetishize
well we can discuss this later because
you've been
obsessed on tick tock and i'm going to
pull them up we're going to watch them
and i want to show you guys the outfit
she rolled up into my house to my family
in
but other than that how was your
experience what did you think of my
family oh gosh
you were disappointed it was real
because you were expecting like the
fish and the yeah and all the crazy and
the pomegranate and the apple and the
is that the one where you blow the goat
yeah the shoehorn
yeah i thought there was gonna i just
was really hungry
i just assumed your family would be good
like no they suck i i
might be always good at cooking this is
why i'm the way i'm at so i thought
we're gonna have a feast we're gonna
have potatoes
and carbs and there was no carbs it was
all chicken
i'm actually going to agree i thought
that meal was for my family we usually
have bad meals but that one was
legendarily bad
like if i knew i would have just ordered
food and no offense to i love my family
it was beautiful though no like the
setup was beautiful the fact that
like everyone was really really nice so
i don't want to say that like honestly
they were super super nice and like it
was
it was great i was just uncomfortable
for so many reasons like we talked about
like i just like i know your dad like
watches like porn and like favorites it
on twitter so that's all i could think
about because i'm sitting right next to
him
and moses told me to cover my boobs too
he's like don't show your boobs so
that's why i wore the t-shirt i wore
the israeli t-shirt to not have my boobs
out so then i was like next to your dad
and i was thinking like oh my god he
loves like
naked tits on twitter and i like that's
all i do on twitter okay let me
let me preface uh my dad
i've warned him i've warned my dad i
says dad you know
like i i've said if you're gonna look at
porn on twitter at least don't like it
because people know who you are because
he makes a point of commenting
all my posts and then he's watching porn
and liking porn on twitter it's like
dude
they can see your likes your likes are
and then also he follows porn stars
oh so i'm going through his followers
and i'm like dude you can't you
you can't be following this [ __ ] but he
but he doesn't listen clearly
yeah i think he's just like in his own
world but he's watching this and he's
probably and then he's like
what do you have i mean what can i do
and so
but they bounced early they were the
first league like okay but peace they
like left
early i guess it was here before no but
this is my family like this is what i'm
trying to tell people
i know ethan looked so sad i kind of
felt bad you looked
just sad really you didn't look happy
tired
i just i felt bad and i didn't say this
to anybody else i just say that's why i
asked you today how you're feeling
because i was just like
oh no there's something wrong i was just
tired i don't think so
i think so you were like awake
you're like looking at twitter and you
were like awake well
well you could be tired and awake you
know i wanted to stay longer to be
honest but mostly no let's go
i mean i agree we both started hanging
out and talking but then everyone
bounces that's my family
they come everything's half-assed they
don't do any of the religious [ __ ]
and then as soon as it's done they all
just want to leave
yeah like you guys don't play games
together like i was ready for like some
fun game nights or something i actually
was gonna bring like categories or i had
heads up on my phone and i was like we
should play and that would never happen
but but hey this is what it is you know
that that's why
can like me and like moses come over for
a family night
like games maybe if we reach
a couple more episodes
because right now what i mean people are
really taking bets how long this is
going to last and
i'm i'm and i'm worried about you and
moses because let me tell you why
why let me pull this [ __ ] up because you
fed it you i don't know that you like
him as a person i think you just
fetishize him i always ask him that too
i'm like i wonder if i just like like
the idea of you you just say that to him
yeah like he's like i don't know if it's
like
he's just different and new and like a
toy so i'm like what is it then
you're gonna i said that to him even
after we oh because of you guys because
you guys are i've been together like 10
years and you guys are just not
affectionate i'm like oh my god is that
going to be us
dude you guys weren't okay stop no
you look like you're just not into each
other ever that's just so
stupid no we like squeeze each other's
butts and stuff and i never once saw
that with you
and i i wrote both of you you know what
this is propaganda
by the way me and el are an extremely
loving relationship you can't
say no and then i worry i'm like oh my
god is that gonna be us like maybe it
will be us in 10 years
how often do you have sex with her um
uh like once a week pretty good i think
are you being serious
yeah you're lying no i'm not lying
just once a week that's pretty good when
you've been married for as long as us
this is what scares me and this is why i
think we'll like end up breaking up like
that's a [ __ ] terrifying
some people have sex more and some
people have sex less i think that's fine
once a week is pretty good when you've
been i mean i'm happy with that
not upset about it i think we're both
happy with the amount of sex yeah
she's a happy trust me i know i don't
know why you think
by the way just because me and elon are
making out at our
family dinner after being married for 10
years doesn't mean we're in a loved one
but you can just tell when someone's
like bye okay well you're wrong i mean i
don't
know i was right well okay well you're
fetishizing her brother and you're in a
[ __ ] relationship
i know i don't know yet we'll see i
don't know maybe
i like i think i'm in love i think like
i'm i like obsessed
with him in so many levels yeah obsessed
is not really the way to do it
describe a healthy relationship okay so
let's watch this
so why are you doing all these israeli
themed tick tocks what
what is this i'm big in israel there's
literally all you do why is that because
tick tock israeli tick tocks that are
big that have like millions of followers
always post me
so you're just trying to i'm big in
israel right now
i'm not kidding you like all these like
israeli celebrities hit me up
and they're like um are you just trying
to tap into that that's it
you talk is that really what it's called
you said hashtag you talk
is real okay this was meant to be a
daily vlog but there are too much good
stuff at the glatt market
i was gonna do a day of my life so i was
showing everything that wasn't jewish
so this was something else you did
hashtag you talk
israeli rosh hashanah fish head
and traditions yeah cause this is like
people don't know why you have a fish
head at rosh hashanah and so forth were
you disappointed we didn't have a fish
yet it was so sad in the pomegranates
she was like wait no fish head yeah that
was really sad your family looked at me
like i was crazy no one knew hebrew i
was ready to speak hebrew with people i
was like so excited about it and it just
didn't happen so you did this one here
i love you talk is now your most common
it's popular i got free falafels here
for wearing an israel shirt
shout out falafel on wheels so
are you if you if you and moses dump
your emails as what dump i meant to say
break up i don't wanna say dump sounds
like you guys took his [ __ ] together
i hear raiding my jew okay this is the
one i had a problem with no
now trisha you know you can't she says
raiding my
jew lunch uh-huh do you not see what's
the problem with that i couldn't fit ish
in there
but jew is like a derogative no my
jew lunch i think it's the way if you
say it i was writing like oh my good
lunch
i can tell you with on with 100
certainty you cannot say that it's
offensive
moses said it was fine and he is from
israel and had a bar mitzvah so he is
well he says it's fine
like moses doesn't care first of all i
have to say he
i'm also a bar mitzvah and he's not a
native english speaker although he
speaks english fluently
right he doesn't understand you can't
say jew lunch can i just tell you every
israeli celeb
two israeli celebrities have hit me up
and said hey i'm a jew from israel
that's different no that's not you can
say i'm a jew from israel but you can't
use
jew as an adjective like jew lunch
sounds [ __ ] up
people can say they're a jew and i can't
say do lunch yeah it's
listen if you want to be all do you know
what i'm saying dan there's the
there's there's a distinction there
i think it's the raiding my jew lunch
dan how how does that sound to you
it depends on the concept thank you you
just said raiding my jew
lunch with a star david it's a fun tick
tock
hey i'm like promoting this like culture
yeah but you're kind of like this is
kind of like
cultural appropriation isn't it
appreciation
right okay that's this i think it is so
many israelis will like be like thank
you so much for like
you know speaking hebrew like a lot of
people like say thank you for it and i
mean there's some that hate it but
there are some that hate it would you
get aid comments yeah i mean there are
certain people that are like
what are they saying i mean that's more
just like people who say free palestine
they get pissed off but i don't know oh
it's not the jews that get in
the american jews that get angry which
aren't real jews you're like
what's like calm down you're from
ventura california
like you know you don't know the
struggle he's israeli
they were slaves in egypt he wasn't a
slave
his ancestors were your ancestors
weren't
wait why well how do you wait because
he's in the land of the free the free
anyways this is you know that wait hold
on you know that jews who
who moved to europe which is where my
ancestors come from
have us common origin that's what being
jewish is
right but they weren't exiled that's why
they live in europe
no so where'd they come from
where'd they come from trisha i don't
know but i know that the people in
israel were exiled from egypt as slaves
where do you think that the people from
europe come from where were they
the same place bro where that's what the
jewish from israel or egypt
from egypt well that's what the bible
says but that's obviously contested
so yeah exactly but it's the same tribe
of people um
we'll have to consult with my expert jew
lover moses but he's not here right now
and i wish he wasn't here
but do you see this this whole obsession
of fetishization makes me a little
uncomfortable it's not
fetishizing it's a preference if i
prefer to date jewish men
okay if you prefer to date i'm just
gonna this might i don't want to come
off too insensitive
it's like i prefer to date black guys
yeah and be like okay that's fine you
like black guys yeah
but then all of a sudden you start going
here's my and
forgive me for being crass but like you
can understand where i'm going
hey here's my fried chicken review why
is it different
that's so different that's literally
what you're doing
no no that's here let me pull up a
youtube video why is that different i
can't even go there first of all
explain how it's different to me it's
different culture
because it's not their culture it's not
their culture it's a stereotype
and so it's not a stereotype that all
jews walk around in idf uniform first of
all
i'm not it's not that me the exact
comparison would be me being like oh
look at my like like what's the
stereotype about jews like oh my
we're cheap cheap chicken nose oh my
yeah
my cheap jew boyfriend with a big nose i
don't say that i'm like do what i like
about the culture
like i'm not like stereotyping anybody i
love hebrew like i love saying things in
hebrew i love like
well let's just like let's judge for
ourselves you uploaded this video
called best hollow bread recipe and by
the way if you guys want to see the
the outfit i want to say costume it's
not a costume
the treasure came to my house and you
can see it here
why are you wearing a beret like you're
going to battle shit's crazy they wear
green berets over there no they don't i
lived there for five years nobody walks
around in berets unless they're an army
i googled yeah i googled israeli soldier
and there's a green beret that comes up
with the green pants so why don't you
dress up as an american soldier when you
just want to
like why are you fetishizing the army
because now this is my new culture
okay all those converting to judaism and
of course just my christians who get
down with the old testament
genesis all the way so today is rosh
hashanah and guess what
why genesis all the way oh genesis is
the reason rosh hashanah
on the the sixth day so you were
announcing the new testament
what you were announcing the new
testament but i also believe in the old
testament as a christian i
also believe in genesis because you know
believing the new testament is like
sacrilege to judaism
that's all a lie right but jews
jew judas jewish people don't
believe in hell so what's it matter if i
believe in the new testament what do
they think
was wrong with me well they just don't
think you're jewish oh well i'm not i'm
i'm jewish by insemination gross what
the [ __ ]
i don't think that's how it works by the
way
we're in the future and we're in that
new year and it is going to be
fire so today i'm going to show you how
you can celebrate the
new year if you so happen to convert we
will watch this i mean
genuinely sweet why would anyone want to
watch this
a different way to make oh the reasons
why we have like the pomegranate and the
all that stuff i explained in this like
a how-to best holiday recipe
that was so good i used all the stuff
from the jewish market
and were you going to say jew market i'm
saying jewish now if does that make you
happy well no it's better it's
definitely better i mean i'm saying it
for your benefit you don't want to walk
around saying jew market that sounds
wrong
okay i'll say jewish from now on yeah
i'm just giving you a tip i thought it
was fine but moses is wrong i mean
i'll just say that objectively he's
wrong here's her eating
apple i mean it's just odd pomegranate
it's odd that all of your content lately
is all jew related
that's why i worry about i worry about
moses because i feel like
he's just a prop in your video and this
whole thing is just
fetishizing you see where i'm coming
from
yeah but in the videos he's in with me
we're just eating we're not talking
about jew stuff when he's in the video
with me
yeah but like so how what how do you
know that he's not just like
a prop for you i don't oh i don't know
do you ever know like what if what if
you're just
yeah i know we've been married for ten
years but maybe it's uh
she just keeps the joke going some
people can really like you know keep it
going
oh i got me an american because what he
told what i heard i'm not gonna say who
told me but what i heard is that israeli
soldiers are supposed to keep amer like
date americans so they bring them over
to israel so there's more
jews that come over to israel you heard
what is it a secret
that's yeah what anyways yeah yeah
i'm happy it worked out for you guys all
i'm saying is like everything starts out
as like a joke or a prop
right but then it becomes real like it's
real now i mean he's work with my family
all the time like
okay all right anyways what else is
going on um
in life yeah oh i might have to sit a
couple shows out because i'm getting
some liposuction a boob job and a lip
job
and you can't do the show when you're
recovering why i'm gonna try and do it
on a tuesday
and so maybe i can come back on a monday
why don't you sit while you're
recovering i think that'd be interesting
which is like bruised up yeah [ __ ] and
then we could talk about the process and
stuff i think that's great i'm getting
some fat into my butt and i don't think
you can actually sit
well we'll stand i'm fine with that it's
only an hour
okay what what what work are you getting
though november um
i'm gonna get my boobs again lipo in my
stomach butt transfer and my lip pushed
up let's
let's go one by one what are we doing
with the boobs boobs i just want them
more fake i need them higher
more fake yeah i want them a little
higher more high profile
because i have a feeling i'm gonna get
like proposed to soon and probably get
married so i want to get this done
before all that happens
so i look snatched you think moses is
going to propose to you
yeah i think so maybe a jew proposal
he's actually can i just clarify for the
record even though he's from israel and
had a bar mitzvah he does not identify
as jewish he doesn't practice he's not
jewish okay whatever whatever i'm over
talking let's talk about your let's talk
about your
your boobs okay he's in love only
trish.com
sorry bleep that you can you can i
didn't get that promo
you can promote yourself we got
paparazzi the other day and i didn't i
didn't plug the only pants and it was a
real paparazzi night okay anyways back
to the boobs but
okay so you you want your tits to look
more fake that's your objective yeah i
want them a little higher
um because i do only i do only some i do
i do like adult
work sometimes i i've seen your boobs
obviously i followed you on twitter for
a brief time
i unfollowed you you really didn't
follow me back no i
i would like i follow you on other
socials i just don't want to see your
[ __ ]
vagina and [ __ ] until it doesn't come
out as much anymore now that like
but anyway but but i've seen your i've
seen your boobs and they have like
really
with peace and love really serious scar
marks
crazy scars what happened there um it's
just from a lift oh you want to know the
reality
i got a lift and i keep looking at
myself
it's okay it's pretty close to the
camera i love looking at myself there's
a previewer right because dan is
we're looking at dan's back you can look
at it i love looking at myself on camera
when i look good
um anyways um no i had i had two
surgeries for the lift and the lip
always is those little scars
the problem is my scars got really big
because like you're not supposed to have
sex six weeks after surgery and i have
it like the day of surgery like as soon
as i get out like having sex oh so you
mean
you messed up so even if you just lay
there you're still being like
pushed and stuff so the scars like or
the there were staples at the time the
staples like split open
oh that's so [ __ ] up can you not if
you want to remind me stars only
twitch.com if you want to see some boobs
you know [ __ ] up
but like i no again with peace and love
i think it's the worst boob job i've
ever seen
so not true no i've never i've never
seen
such scarring before can i show it now
or no
no well we can't show it
okay um and then frankly uh because i
showed the guys at impulsive and they
said that they looked fine like
seriously and i was like i know they're
[ __ ] up they're whatever and they're
like let's see and i was like okay
well i actually i offered i mean i've
seen i've seen them but they're and they
were like
those aren't bad like and because i'm
like because everyone on twitter tells
me you're just gonna
you're on the twitter trailer i wanna
look you in the face be like your tits
are [ __ ] up lady
no because i even said oh my god look
how [ __ ] up these are like i was
excited to show cause i hear it on
twitter all the time i was like oh my
god my kids are so [ __ ] let me show
you
and they're like no and they were brutal
with me like honestly i did not like
logan i didn't care for him when i went
on the podcast like that whole
they were very misogynistic in my
opinion so you showed them the tits on
or off
on camera oh they just blurred it uh
yeah and then
i and they were the whole time they were
kind of nasty to me during the interview
so like that was the time i'm like oh
well this will say something and they
were like
oh like those aren't even bad like and
they were brutal with me like the whole
time by the way so i wasn't like
i don't think they were being polite
look i don't care like my boobs are my
boobs i mean i get boob jobs all the
time so i'm ready for another one and
i'm just like ready but like
if you keep doing the boob job does it
help i mean at a certain point do they
like take it out and redo it
yeah oh they do yeah it's a full restart
this is better than what it was can they
change your skin
yeah they change my nipples my nipples
used to be and now they're like you've
got new nips
i can't feel them moses always like and
i'm like i can't feel it he tries and
like
don't bring up your sex life with moses
please ever
i don't know anything about it i love
him he's not here like that's not the
longest we've been apart it's so weird
like
i like i never thought you [ __ ] with the
door open my face when he's
no we have like five bathrooms in my
house so we go separate
we know someone's gone for a long time
like it's probably that and then what
else are you getting done
my stomach light boat again i had one
light bone it did it did help
because my body's more like in now so i
want my waist to go a little more in and
then i'm going to have it transfer to my
butt so my butt's just a little more
round so you take the fat from your
stomach and you put it in your ass yeah
i did that once
before that's a pretty epic procedure i
oh should i show you the before and
afters can i show that or no
let's not okay because it's insane you
wouldn't believe it actually so is it to
make you look skinnier or to
contour your body or what yeah it brings
your wasting can i just show you i feel
like i could just show you
yeah you can show me that it's like it's
like you know what i mean are you afraid
that like
what do you think about kim kardashian's
ass because i feel like it looks like
outrageous wait why do you think it
looks bad because it looks like she has
two tumors on her ass it looks so
unnatural
i haven't seen it are you sure maybe
it's a photoshop sometimes people
photograph
their haters okay here it is oh no this
is way more information no but like this
is okay first of all i'm not gonna lie
my body was
[ __ ] disgusting before but now it's
like kind of like legit
okay this is okay you guys i'm just
gonna describe what i'm seeing
you don't have any nip where's your
nipples yeah they're a little high
the nipples kind of [ __ ] up in my
boobs what it looks like you don't have
nipples
um they're like they're right there like
seeing it you can kind of see
yeah they're okay my nipples are high
like oh my gosh yeah the stars are
so wait i'm seeing
she's butt naked and she doesn't have
nipples
um and but like wow i mean is that crazy
though
but why do you look more tan in that one
this is like a fake before and after
what are you talking about because this
one you're paying on this one i got
spray tans because i had scars where my
lipo was see the liposcar so i was
getting spray tan so the thing are a
light bowed
but look at my waist like even now my
waist yeah i gained some weight back
from this photo but like my waist is
still in like they brought my waist and
my hips you see they took fat from here
and put it on my hips
and then wait the this oh look
but look how much rounder it is she
showed me her ass and it's
[ __ ] what are the three dots there
that's the lipo from the back so they
took fat off
they even got your back fat yep and then
what are they ejected into your ass
so they put some on the hips and then
the ass is right there in the crack
ew why is there something in your crack
that's the scar
that's the stitches it's like you got
poop on your crack it's not poop it's
stitches
so yeah that's that and then i i got my
arms done too let me see if i can find
the arms
there's the arms that's the after but my
arms were like crazy
gross too like those are my arms before
i did gain some weight back so like my
arms are still kind of gross but they're
not as gross as they used to be anyways
it's whatever don't wait so
when you're eating like binge eating and
gaining weight you're like it's all good
i'll just put it in my ass
do you kind of have that thought um
right now only because i know i'm gonna
get the surgery so now i do but i didn't
before
but can't your ass certainly has a
capacity for how much fat it could hold
um
yeah but it like it'll just it'll
disintegrate itself so like
if it can't hold the fat it just won't
take like the fat won't like stick you
know what i mean so like it just
you'll just have you just won't it'll
just disintegrate basically it's not
like harming it it's not going to be
there
those images are going to be branded in
my mind forever dude
we have similar body types maybe
but i would never show that [ __ ] to you
i would never do that to you you had on
twitter i had to see your bare ass on
twitter
that's true and i sent it to moses and i
was like yo well it was on twitter it
wasn't like a big [ __ ] leak
anyway anyway so we discovered that so
when you're going to get that done i
think you should come on the show you
can't skip
yeah i'm going to try and do it as a
weird planning i'm not going to do it on
a tuesday so it's like after the show
and then like come back because you can
do stuff like a week after it's just
like you're
so i'm trying to do it november what
else
um what else with you i keep like i feel
like you're the one that's sad and like
why do you i'm not i just feel like you
need intervention because like your
podcast you lead it always like the h3
you're always leading it you're always
talking and whatever but i feel like no
one's really like
you're the one i'm worried about like i
just feel like you're gonna i don't know
i'm scared of what i don't know like a
twitter headline or something i know i'm
like scared
what what i'm so sad but like a twitter
headline
wait what does that mean i'm going to
kill myself
what what is a twitter house no just
like i don't know i don't want to give
me an example of what a twitter headline
about me would look like i don't want to
even put it out there
say it what's on your mind you obviously
think of something specific just saying
you're okay say it i didn't envision
like two visions of you like
driving off a bridge i don't think you
did it on purpose
and that's why i'm like worried because
i had two and they were very strong
since
the last so what was the other one or
they're both meeting they're both the
same
and they were like it's not dreams it's
like in the middle of the day i'm like
oh my god and then i'm like it's like
it's like a and i don't have those at
all ever about anybody and i like
literally had had it twice since last
monday's podcast
okay are you just okay that's all yeah
i'm fine i'm not go i'm not planning
i'm not suicidal i don't even know if
it's a suicidal thing or someone driving
you off like if someone is someone
following you maybe it's you i mean
wouldn't that make more sense no
because like i don't know if you saw
like after after our practice i do like
an after show on my channel so i did
like an after show mukbang where i got
jollibee afterwards and i was like
telling about my experience on the
podcast this podcast so i was like
directing the traffic back because
like people watching me too and then i
was just like i literally was saying
like oh i really like
love you as like a friend like you
remind me of like myself
like we were both very like have sad
upbringings like we're kind of sad on
the inside
and you kind of remind me of like shane
a little too so i kind of feel like this
like
weird connection with you and it's like
weird like oh i get where you're coming
from and after being around your family
i was like oh i get it
and so that's why i was like oh i should
check in with him though i'm fine
okay you seem fine
now i think i'm sad okay it's just
behind your eyes like you look happy
everything looks happy
but no i'm fine thank you um i'm gonna
be taking a drive
up north today and you may not be
hearing from me again for a while though
so
stop why don't you guys go on like
vacations why don't you guys do anything
but we usually do but there is a
pandemic it's kind of hard and we have a
kid who's one year old
mm-hmm so you know do you do anything
exciting like i feel like you guys just
don't
no exciting no and it sucks because you
guys will text at all hours of the night
like you text me you'll text moses and
i'm like don't they have a
life like texting at midnight on a
friday night no i know it's sad
i agree we have no life it is sad we
just work so what are you gonna do to
spice it up
well last time a few like a month or two
ago we gave the kid
to my parents for two days that was
pretty epic and what'd you do
nothing we just sat at home and watched
tv that was fun do you guys ever do
molly to gather
mushrooms we used to a long time yeah
where in israel
uh we did did some here but yes i'm in
israel we used to do
we've we haven't done mushrooms together
but we've done molly together we've done
it a lot of times together and how do
you feel molly
great like do you feel horny do you feel
loving do you feel
relaxed not horny just more like loving
and happy take it and you're like let's
do it but you haven't done it we've
tried well the thing is we've we've
tried having sex on it
but you can't not it's not really a sex
but the way that we used to do it is
just sit at home and and just feel good
do you want to come over and do
something no i'm too old for that [ __ ]
it's like it's just not worth it you
know what but you don't why how often do
you do it
oh not often but like it's fun i have
some i don't have some
do i get in trouble i don't have any at
my house well it's all it's all
hypothetical
hypothetically yeah they say what do
they say on twitch in minecraft
in minecraft yeah yeah i have mdma in my
car um
i just feel like you might need that
like that's what i was thinking is like
me so the issue is
even if i wanted to take you up on that
because i'm on antidepressants i can't
take
anything like that okay yeah because it
what are you on
um lexapro
what it's not yikes it's some really
common
you should go on zoloft because i feel
like that's the kind of people that do
want to like have suicidal
even if you don't think you're suicidal
you have suicide oh my god i'm not
suicidal
dude lexapro is like it's newer and ever
and it has like
really good everyone who takes it is
really good experience with it it's a
really good drug oh so
don't disparage lexapro i you know what
i've actually never been on
antidepressants so i can't i don't know
anything about them so i
respect but you could do coke on it yeah
i don't like coke okay
you just want to do drugs with me i'm
just trying to get you excited about
life you know
no i yeah i don't know i mean i'm just
gonna i really think i'm just gonna
drive off a bridge after this
no the thing is i i like smoking
cigarettes but they're so bad
ah that's fun we should do that just
blaze smoke
cigarettes all day yeah but i smoke one
and then i feel bad
i do i i have to admit to you i feel
very bored
a lot of the time okay so what do you
but what do you like or not
bored but like well first of all i love
my work and and i i love also where's
the podcast going and i love the team
i love working collaborative with all
these guys it's it's great
and uh the direction and the content
we're making i'm really happy and
satisfied with
teddy fresh is amazing my wife i love
her she's amazing my son
everything's great but like you know
it's very it gets very
monotonous what could you what would you
do if you could do anything right now
like
there's no cover nothing like what would
you do that would be like your dream
hmm i think it'd be fun just to like
jump off or drive off a bridge no i'm
kidding i think it'd be fun to just
take a i'd love to get on a plane and go
somewhere with you but like
where to europe or hawaii or some [ __ ]
all these are 600 right now playing
tickets it's not the price it's
the [ __ ] the disease go first class
and like those little like
suites where you don't see it but you're
on a like guitar first class
no i can't i'm not doing it i'm not
going anywhere why
because the because of the pandemic
okay well you can't just live life
honestly i'm not
i i'm being responsible i mean people
have to do their part here
i mean yeah but like people die of like
people are dying with related causes
it's not just like
i get corona oh you're a cova truther i
don't know don't come for me because i
actually don't know and i'm really
ignorant and dumb
please put that in the propaganda no but
but no but that's true no of course
kovid complicates any medical issue you
have so let's say did you say that word
on youtube i think you have to say c or
something
no you can say it okay they changed the
policy yeah you're like tight with
youtube yeah um no can i say i know two
people
not like super close to me but two
people that died of covid but it was
the family even was like no it's like
this is what happened they were like
sick before this is
and i'm not saying like i don't know
okay let me ask you this yeah i don't
know
i'm literally if you're sick and you're
f you're sick but you're stable
then you catch covet and die what killed
you
i think you i think the blue it's like a
flu like it's like a relationship
complications from covet that's what
they call it this person would be alive
if they didn't catch covet i mean i know
two people who died in the hospital and
they were like
totally they were just going in for like
a routine surgery and then like died
toe so coveted i mean i
i get it i'm just saying like are you
gonna live your life i mean like oh my
god like
yes i'm so scared to even know but
here's here's what i think
there's a lot of people who cannot live
in a way
there's people that have to go to work
and there's people that have to put
themselves in harm's way of this disease
there's people like me who has a life of
luxury who's you know privileged in
every way
so people like me should just buck the
[ __ ] up and stay home
because if i can do my part to not
spread this disease then i
then i have i'm obligated to do that i
agree so do some molly with ila then
you're like i can't do molly i'm on
antidepressants oh
[ __ ] i probably would if i wasn't but
that's it yeah but the antidepressants
is more important
mushrooms you can microdose on
antidepressants
i'll have to look into that you do damn
you're stacked you got everything
in minecraft oh my god can i get
arrested though for real no
no oh my god i do not want to get
arrested
[ __ ] but no you're fine it's only in
minecraft oh my god
actually i'll have to look into that
because yeah mushrooms could be fun
the problem is that when you have
responsibility we're doing the show and
we have a kid and all this [ __ ] it's
just
i don't i don't want i know but like i
always have really horrible hangovers
it's just too risky it's not bad
especially with mushrooms sometimes it's
not bad sometimes it's bad i've had so
i'm just telling you i think it's the
people you do it with and like no one
ever had a bad trip with beam
nope um it's not a bad trip it's a bad
hangover
because then like i'm [ __ ] up for a
few days and i'm like dude i have [ __ ]
to do
i can't do it for sure i get it how
about only fans
my what you're starting to leave no
i thought you were going to oh for like
a joke
no for like really you should try see
how much money you make you're all about
money like as soon as tick-tock you
heard you can make money like i'm on
tick-tock now
what i make like five dollars a day no
you're all about the money and not just
because you're jewish
it's because you're just that's not true
i'm really not all about the money
why do you say that i know this based on
based on everything that i've heard
about you that i know about you you've
heard about me
driven and that's fine that's just not
true
it's not true that i'm money driven are
you a gemini
no what are you i'm not telling you
because then you'll be like oh that's so
you you are nothing i'm not a gemini
i just hate gemini well i'm not a gemini
okay what are you
i'm not gonna tell you unless you tell
me i'm a cancer oh
oh my god you're literally shane i
literally said that because you're in
july
what are you what's your birthday july
what i'm not born in july
what what's your sign tourist yeah i
knew you were taurus [ __ ] i hate taurus
such a tourist oh my god i knew you were
very shane asked because you have both
cancers that means you're very sensitive
i do know about cancers because like my
best friend obviously can i ask you
something
how is it possible that everybody born
in the same month
has the same characteristics as a person
that's literally you're saying
it's it's so ridiculously absurd the
notion of astrology
i agree to some degree but i do like
everybody who's ever born in june is
has the same exact characteristic it's
crazy i mean gemini's for sure
that's the june yeah well
sounds great and you're very sensitive
but i'm not but first of all i resent
you saying that i'm
money-driven because i really don't
think i am you really are
i think i'm money-driven as much as
anybody else but i don't think i'm
extraordinarily money driven no you're
you are you weren't on tick tock until
you realized you could make money off of
it
what that's not true so why'd you join
tick tock why did anyone what does
anyone join tick though why did you join
tic tac i'm asking you
okay because i started seeing a ton of
tick tocks and we keep always talking
about on the show
and i wanted to understand what it was
and then once i got in there i started
really having fun
it's not about money i was like oh this
these are really fun to make like i made
this dumb [ __ ] baba booey
tick tock and then people like
people liked it people started liking
the content i was making there and i
i was having fun making tick tocks like
in a way i haven't had fun making videos
in a really long time
i was i'm like it's been so long since i
wanted to pull out my phone and make a
video you know like back back back in
the day
oh yeah and so i was like dude tick tock
is my home
[Music]
i kind of resent that as someone who's
been on tactical and let me tell you
this if i'm money driven why the [ __ ]
would i care about making five dollars a
day
moses said the day he was over here
you're like i made twenty dollars
it's a joke was it though to your family
you just sit around and joke because
when i was here you're not just sitting
around and joking you were very serious
what is twenty dollars
i mean what is that life changing money
i'm excited about my money on tick tock
i show everybody too
look i'm not okay your point has it
really only been 40 minutes dan
oh god i feel like it's so [ __ ] long
there's a timer there i was like this
[ __ ] over yet
oh remember not to come next week then
now we have to do it for the people
and you're not invited to my wedding
can you do that yes yeah which one none
of them
i just i find that offensive i find you
offensive
so um you wanna imagine being like
hey guys look i made 20 bucks on tick
tock he's a money
driven greedy jew it's basically what
you're saying didn't say that
um no but i'm saying you joined because
cody ko was on the podcast and he's like
i'm making money off adsense i joined
before that
we weren't making and cody showed me he
made three dollars and i was like
wow i need to be a part of that because
you saw potentially like i need to get
in on this ground before it starts
really
around outrageous you can't say [ __ ]
like that
i know and even when you were joking
about starting only fancy like i'm gonna
do it as a joke and see if morning money
again but you're gonna get that
i don't like that that characterization
because people always say that like
i'll do this i feel like people make
that characterization against me because
i'm jewish
let me explain if you compare me to any
other creator
i'm just as money driven as any of them
but for some reason i get this
label as like money driven and greedy
and all this even though i'm doing
literally the same thing as
everybody else yeah why is it that i
have to take that label because you try
and be like sneaky about it you try and
be like schlubby like i don't care about
money
meanwhile just getting in where all the
cash grabs are only fans ticked i'm not
only fans but you wanted to as like a
joke but you wanted to get it i wouldn't
get that cash grab
yeah but i didn't make it only fans and
i never would
who the [ __ ] gonna pay me to be on the
only fan a lot of people um
do you watch them you know you do that
wait what
when you end the sentence you go um
i literally have no idea you know a lot
of people um
you did that right then no definitely
not and i don't think it's because
you're jewish there's lots of jews on
on youtube that don't casey neistat
doesn't get that critique
dude case is he jewish how would you
dude casey neistat is so money driven
no bro he's like the brand anymore he's
like mr brand
no he spends money he's not coming for
airlines
25 000 first class ticket
he spends the money okay so your
evidence that i'm money driven is that i
made it only fans which i never did
and that i'm on tick tock anything else
i mean look you abandoned the h3
channel to do how was that proof that
i'm money driven did you have something
to make money which was the podcast but
now you're focused on teddy fresh
because that's making you guys your
money now
so you just go where the money goes what
if and i know this is crazy so bear with
me we
do what we like and it just so happens
that we like doing the podcast and we
like doing teddy freddy so you didn't
like doing your channel anymore no i've
said that a billion times i didn't like
doing the channel
but why because you weren't making as
much money literally at the beginning
you were making a lot of money
and now you're not making money so of
course when we switched to the podcast
we were making way more money doing that
than this only now that we've been doing
we've been doing this for three years so
why the [ __ ] shouldn't i
not want to make money doing it money is
a byproduct of doing something you're
passionate about
i don't i don't agree i do youtube
videos every single day and i make no
money
i make like well that's because nobody
watches your content because it sucks
i think it's more because i'm not
friends with popular youtubers anymore
like i was friends with
shane and then david and then exactly my
views do not go up from being on this
yeah well they're not gonna nobody cares
but you know why but this podcast is
doing really well the first episode was
a
um hit yeah i think so i don't know
yeah it did really well why people like
it
[Laughter]
i yeah but i think it was like a novelty
thing like okay it's our first episode
like well you know but then after a
while i think people are like yeah
well then i got canceled after nine
months for my my own podcast i'm
very confident that i'll be canceled
from this in nine months as well well
we'll see
you better bring the thunder i was
trying to push it and then now i'm going
ah whatever i guess no one's gonna watch
i think it's the combination
that makes it special of who of us yeah
but like we like each other now i feel
like before like there was genuine
hatred
well i'm a little upset that you're
basically calling me a greedy jew and
saying i'm gonna
kill myself by driving off a bridge
that's pretty bizarre i was
genuinely concerned about you this whole
week i kind of got worried i was like oh
should i reach out with them like it's
kind of weird
and we're only in a group chat we're not
in a like a one-on-one chat
you're sure have you always been a
strange person what were you like as a
kid
this is not an interview this is a
podcast we should be talking about
as a canada i was i was great i mean i
literally don't even remember childhood
like to me i had so much trauma that i
blacked it out like i swear i on my life
so with the i i mean can you just kind
of just tell me what kind of trauma you
had
like i i'm not even kidding like i've
gone to therapy and like like
remember trauma like that's what i'm
saying like i swear i was like oh i had
a great childhood
just like molesting and stuff like
honestly like it was just stuff that i
didn't even know like i have to like
yeah no i've heard that i like blacked
out literally all child like high school
i don't feel like i went to even high
school and that's the truth like i don't
even know so hang on you're
you're close with your parents yeah so
they didn't abuse you or anything no
so what happened to you i don't know
so how do you know you i mean i think
i'm figuring it out i just started
therapy like
something is well well it wasn't an
attempt i was hold i wasn't an attempt
but they said i hadn't attempted a
suicide attempt
went to a mental hospital when i got out
i was like i should probably get some
therapy
am i slouching too much dan or is it fun
sorry i know you're talking i know
you're talking to me about
you're [ __ ] wanting to kill yourself
but let me just make sure i'm in frame
tell yourself me kill myself
well okay so why are you interested
yeah that's disgusting look at that that
is [ __ ] future
bro don't look like that whatever
happened to the lighting dude
oh lee well it's just comfortable i
gotta sit back
so you love you have a great
relationship with your family so why are
you so [ __ ] up
i don't know i honestly don't know it's
a lot of unpacking i mean i do
but like it's something i haven't even
worked through all the way because you
went into prostitution
like at what age oh early like 18.
so how do you come out of a good family
and go straight into prostitution
um what happened was is like
okay like it was good my mom was good
the thing was my mom she had a lot of
boyfriends she was married a lot of
times
your parents were divorced yeah they got
divorced early on and so
my mom worked all the time she was a
single mom like she my dad like paid a
little bit but whatever
so my mom worked like four jobs always
had boyfriends the boyfriends are always
at her house without my mom and like
just like
in and out just like did the boyfriend
ever touch you i don't know honestly i
don't know but like all i knew was like
i had to get out so at 17 i was like
peace bye i'm like actually i quit
school at 15 but then i got brought back
into school but my dad was homeschooling
it was a thing anyways so i was like i
moved out in la at 15 and then i had my
i was brought back home at like 16 and
then i like moved out again at 17
and then my dad said he'd take me
because he lives in california and like
what really pushed me
to answer your question is like my dad
was like oh you have to go to college
and all of a sudden i was like i want to
go to college like whatever i got a tv
show when i was 18. i got a
like a full-time gig on the show called
the greg barrett show he wrote the book
he just got that into you and it was a
huge production at sony
and my dad's like absolutely not you're
not gonna do it cause i was a guest
controlling dad
um i look like no yes controlling but
like nice like you know well why didn't
he want you to do the show cause he just
wanted me to go to college he's like
you're gonna go to college
and and they him and my stepmom i lived
with them my stepmom would like tell me
like not to wear certain things anyways
they were like a little controlling
whatever but my dad was my dad's a great
now i love my dad but
um so then i was like [ __ ] i'm gonna
go do this tv show the tv show gets
canceled like six months in
and i there was a bunch of episodes
there online so i did a bunch of
episodes with him and it got canceled
six months in
and i got this other reality show called
toronto superhero stan lee i was on a
show with stan lee and so like i was
getting all these like jobs at 18.
and then like all of a sudden like i
wasn't getting paid anymore and i was
like [ __ ]
and so i didn't know what to do i tried
to get like regular jobs and like i
don't know i like literally couldn't
work like it was yeah you
you can i can see you at chipotle i was
working at disney soda phone and got
fired
disney what soda fountain it's the
ghirardelli factory now right
um oh i can't say
you better sell it right i can't say how
bad could it be a disney soda factory i
don't
because i think they released me for a
different reason i think they were
telling me
how long ago was that tell me right now
i was definitely having sex inside
the restaurant see there's something
wrong with you there's something that
happens
yeah for sure okay so you were caught
having sex inside of the restaurant
yeah like not even in the bathroom and
they just wear like inside and now
the customers there yeah it's not even
the soda phone anymore i literally
literally shut it down like
two weeks later i'm not joking like all
jokes aside like it literally shut that
[ __ ] down
i don't know that's and and and so when
you would have sex in the restaurant
would you like go serve customers would
you wash your hands i just met a
customer that was like you [ __ ] a
customer
i have something wrong with me with sex
for sure there's definitely holy [ __ ]
tell me about that encounter i want to
know how that went down i can't really
say full details of it
please tell me this is so interesting
don't use names or anything just
i want to know how this goes don't do it
that often honestly they were having a
premiere next door at the el capitan
and so like they were coming over and
like this guy i was like in love with
and i was like holy [ __ ] well you just
well based on just
first sight yeah but he was on major
drugs i wasn't i was completely sober
okay what do you look like why were you
in love with him um just hands like a
session
can i say i'm not really i don't really
find looks on people i don't find people
attractive or unattractive i really
don't for the most part
okay but this guy was beautiful yeah and
so he was in movies and stuff so like
he's a movie star yeah oh so when i was
18
so he was at the premiere yeah oh don't
clock that because i can do my no no no
i'm not i'm not going to investigate but
so what happened so a movie star
people do ambassadors no no we're not
going to visit i might tell a story no
no people got it wrong when you told the
story about like someone shot at you
people didn't guess it right
yeah yeah well some people some people
did but anyways
anyways it was the guy was
just out of his mind and then i was like
i wasn't but i was like [ __ ] it so he's
like just coming on my lap
he came to the restaurant he had a
group of people with them so his
entourage came into the restaurant
and you were waiting on them and they
had a vip because they were like you
know
vip so they were like and then and then
so he said come sit on my lap
and so what happened no you just stick
out
in front of his entourage yeah this was
when they had like sure
but it was very like waiting for oh so
you were okay hold on hold on hold on
wow i don't know if i should say this
story honestly so you're
waiting i got fired for nail polish well
who cares they're out of business what
the [ __ ] you're doing your own disney is
huge they're like the illuminati like
they could come for me
this thing's not coming for you look you
remember how paranoid when i showed your
earnings you thought youtube was gonna
ban your account
no i probably did because ever since
then i started making zero dollars i
make like 500
now yeah that's not and i was making so
much i was making i showed not so much
but i was making money okay
so you're waiting on you're waiting on
the guy
hold on this is fascinating you're
waiting on the guy
he says come sit on my lap was there any
flirtation before that yeah like you
could just feel like there was a trap
yeah he says come sit on my lap and you
sat and he just took his dick out
or did he say anything or did he just
take his dick no it definitely was not
saying anything i was just more like he
kind of went
like this oh he knew you were down yeah
so it almost sounds like he kind of
raped you
but he knew you were down yeah he knew
because like if you say like no
or like you know yeah yeah you can put
out a vibe and someone can have sex with
you don't have to say yeah have sex with
me please yes
so in front of his whole entourage he
took his dick out put it in you
and then you were just kind of riding
him like this yeah but it wasn't even
[ __ ] like it was definitely just
like
well he penetrated you yeah
never what has never been
you mean with him or like ever ever i
know i didn't for a long time i just i
don't
i i you need to though honestly like
people i'm surprised like i swear people
always like trisha's got so many stds
i'm like i
honestly i would be that first person i
honestly would tell you like i would be
the first person like yeah [ __ ] don't
do this [ __ ] i got [ __ ] herpes or
something like i'm
shocked to this day that i don't have
that like so he put it in you no
protection
did his entourage know he was [ __ ]
you
you know what when i say i was sober i
was over from drugs i did have a couple
shots i'm not sure
okay i can't i think and then when did
they confront you like what are you
doing
in the act uh yeah they just called me
like
they just call me over and they're just
like while you guys were [ __ ] and
they're like trisha come on
they literally yeah someone came by and
said i need to leave you or something
like that
yeah it was bad it was awful like it was
honestly traumatized like this is
there's a lot of traumatizing events
during this time but this was one of the
most traumatizing
i mean i definitely what about it was
traumatizing because it sounds like you
it was all
just embarrassing and yeah i think i
just had issues like who does that like
who's just like oh well obviously
like sometimes okay you know what i mean
nobody does that and then
um at that time too i got i i got mugged
a couple times like it was crazy i got
like
there were some times wait i feel like
you're not telling me more about like
did you
contact this person afterwards at all
how would i like and what who was this
person
why are you protecting them did you did
you ever meet them after this
yes oh okay and they live near me and i
don't think they remember the incident
because i did look so different back
then so i don't think they know
who was it i'm not gonna tell you
because like i'm kind of cool with them
will you tell me off camera no you're
just a big mouth
you're such a big mouth what i
perspective
no you do not you tell people you tell
people [ __ ]
i i resent that i resent that that's not
true represent that people well i have
like
i thought dan wasn't allowed to laugh at
my jokes he said that dan like he told
dan not to laugh at me
yeah give him a prayer i give him uh
first of all i like dan here i'm
i don't want to replace him with ian
well you may not have a choice for the
matter but why
because sometimes they you know they
have [ __ ] to do and they
they come i don't like the other two
when they comment on base three
i know this is an h3 but i'm just saying
well technically it is okay so
so can you give me a hint to who he was
because i'm super
but this is actually really this is a
bad story do you have
i'm just curious why is it so bad i feel
like you're not telling me something
because it sounds like you consented he
consented
but obviously it's embarrassing to get
fired on the spot but
what was it that was i think there's
just a lot more to the story that i
can't tell you that's what i'm getting
there is a lot more isn't there so it's
just it just
keeps going this is the best tell me
come on
this is like you want to get kicked off
the podcast yeah i'm more than you
better keep it interesting
gonna get me in trouble well don't say
who it is he
said yourself you said you're so i won't
highlight it if you don't want me to
don't highlight it because i don't make
any money off the highlights
tell me the story i'll use my name on
the highlights but i don't get a
percentage of the highlights
you won't talk about it okay you guys
want to know the deal we have
let me tell you about this incredible
deal you when i started thinking about i
was like wait this isn't like the best
deal
it is a [ __ ] phenomenal dude okay
first of all the highlights don't make
your highlights alone don't make that
much money we're talking maybe at best a
couple thousand dollars all the ones of
me and moses were at a million and your
other ones do not
a million yeah if you go to your
highlights yes they are go
oh you mean before we started collabing
you want me to give all my guests this
is before the podcast i'm just saying in
general over time my highlights do well
but continue
okay trisha gets 45
of all the podcast revenue including ads
and adsense i get 55 percent guess who
dropped like 50 000
on this setup and has all this gear and
this guy
and all these people working for me
that's a good idea
you're gonna get the 100 of the
highlights i can't get 10 of the
highlights
it's just no like a little something
because you use my name trisha paytas
and i'm like well
i'm promoting the show can i get a
little
it's not that much money because now
you're like trisha paytas talked two off
you know what i mean like it's like
those kind of things her seventy
thousand dollar pick and i never even
showed it on my channel
i'm like well maybe i gotta i don't i
think the deal is pretty good
any money anyways got this podcast it's
one of those things my podcast my in
total of nine months i made eight
thousand dollars no you'll make more
than that
we'll make you know you'll make good
money from this i mean we don't have
sponsors yet but the adsense is good
have a teddy fresh collab
what what does that mean can i have a
teddy fresh collab
we'll collab with like you you're like
person your person yeah trisha paytas
but
teddy fresh yeah trish by teddy trishan
teddy
hmm maybe we could do an item i'm not
sure i'll have to i mean obviously
me and you are close now we're good i
like her do you not feel the deal is
fair because i feel like it's
it's more than fair i don't think so
like over time you're gonna do all these
dude
how am i ever gonna even make back the
investment let's be honest i spent like
50 000
on all this [ __ ] you didn't spend
anything i dealt with all of it
where this podcast is going to break up
before i even recoup myself
how about recoup it with the highlights
and then i get 45 of the highlights
recoup from the highlights how about
even 30 because i know you have to pay
people
hold on hold on here and edit hold on
hold on hold on
recoup the highlights if i'm making a
couple thousand dollars a month that's
going to take like two years
you're gonna make more than a couple
thousand one of those will blow just
from the highlights yeah something's
gonna get like
dan do you not think that's a fair deal
yeah
to get zero of the highest the highlight
is not a big deal
i was like let me just keep the
highlight money to keep it simple to
help
and you'll and 45 of everything is a lot
i mean dude you don't do any you
literally just show up
you're gonna make way more money recoup
the 50 000 before you pay me anything
anywhere
and then 45 and 55 for everything else
i mean that's yeah okay you so you're so
you're hedging your bets on
this podcast lasting more than a few
episodes
i didn't get paid [ __ ] for my last
podcast i don't really give a [ __ ] i can
already tell you that the adsense was
really good on our first podcast so
you're gonna get a nice check at the end
of the month right that quick
just i'm going to pay you at the end of
every month cool okay cool and a tiny
fresh cloud we'll call it even
i just i think you should be very happy
can i just say i would kill it selling
like
like i feel like when i wear teddy fresh
some people don't know what tiny fresh
is i know that's like hard to believe
because i know teddy fresh is popping
i'm not gonna take that away from you
but i'm just saying some people really
do ask me like
when i wore that mint and green so many
were like where is this from they did
not know it was teddy fresh so i feel
like
i never want to make you want to be a
brand ambassador
yeah but i want to collab like i want to
be trisha paytas by teddy
freddy oh you want us yeah i think we
well so do you care if we sell it on our
website or if we just make it like for
you
either way i don't care if it's on yours
because we could i mean we can make
anything you want our production
our manufacturing capacity is really
good now very impressed and i was just
like we can make anything now it's crazy
i know i saw some upcoming designs i'm
like oh and you know what i just never
really like i don't like cheap [ __ ] like
i don't like that android crap you know
what i mean like that's i love mine no
we don't make cheap [ __ ] yet yeah no i
know i love buying merch and i like i
just feel like mine would kill it like
we do some pink and sparkles and like
literally the thing is like we obviously
specialize in unisex we're opening a
female department i think it comes out
next month but like dresses and stuff
although we
we just don't have experience in-house
with like fitting and stuff so
dressing would be hard a really sexy
blonde holding a little teddy bear
i mean hoodies and stuff we could do
anything you want like that's easy
dresses and stuff is is more difficult
we could do it but it takes it will take
a long time to fit it doesn't need to be
like a fashion like i want it to be like
not merged but you know like i mean like
it could be like just like a sparkly
bling collab you know like a bling why
don't you send me some inspiration of
stuff and then i'll i'll pitch it i feel
like i'm pretty good at it
i'll come to a pitch meeting if you want
to draw sketch or just
save some inspiration oh yeah i'm gonna
move the sketchup for me because i can
tell him yeah
um we have 30 seconds left go ahead no
you have you what is your what were you
talking about so who did you [ __ ] who
did you [ __ ] in the restaurant
i won't highlight it i'll go longer tell
me more
but what are the details you're not
telling me it's so fast so traumatizing
like that's all i should have to tell
you
okay you're literally like pulling well
well no because you made it sound like
okay all right i'll leave it look even
my traumatic events i found enjoyable
but my therapist is like no that [ __ ]
you up for life and i'm like oh well
that was fine for me you know what i
mean so that's what i'm saying but i
it's just like there's a lot i can't say
and i don't want to trigger anyone
trigger warning you should put a trigger
warning before
i didn't i didn't i don't know what it
was it sounds like you were assaulted
and
i didn't know that general i'm just
saying no i'm not saying anything i'm
not like i'm offended i'm just saying
like in general you should put like a
trigger warning before our podcast
why because we talked about trigger
warning we talked about
driving off a bridge and like you
brought that up out of nowhere what the
f well how do i know
you're going to i didn't envision you
driving off i just saw your car going
off so it could like someone could have
drove it like
chased you off or something you know
what i mean or the bridge was faulty i
don't know who's tracing me you're gonna
[ __ ] kill me
you psycho no i'm never gonna kill you i
promise you
you're gonna chase my ass off a bridge
oh
i love you this is like such a good like
feng shui right now
you like it now because you never look
at my eyes ever and you're staring me
deep in my soul oh no i'm looking away
well i saw trisha naked a day was
horrific no offense
well that was my before and i uh i saw i
saw the afters too they were there they
were great
they were all horrific
well there you go episode two we did it
how can we cut right at an hour why
can't we go two hours your age three
goes two hours
no we're cutting it all back because i
because we're making
four episodes a week now and i think i
don't it's just hard to produce that
much content like
it all it affects everybody like the
highlights dan editing
my energy because now i have to go prep
for tomorrow so i have to be responsible
so don't wear yourself thin about it no
no i'm not i'm happy with the workload i
just need to
make sure that do we get guests on this
ever or no that's only for h3
i'm open to it if you have a good one
but i don't see the point i mean the
whole thing is the dynamic
yes i just feel like are you tired of
talking to me already it's only second
episode this doesn't sound
i love having guests on my podcast like
guests are so fun
i had brett michaels on my podcast that
was a lot of fun who's that
is that a from poison and rock of love
you're such a stupid you're so stupid
also
also announcement um we're gonna be
starting halloween
october 5th on this podcast so my first
costume our first
you should be oh i can dress up that'll
be fun each week i have each monday i
already have a costume plan
really yeah that's awesome so october
5th october 12th
october 19th and december 26th i'm
stoked well i'm gonna have a costume
yeah that'll be don't know that awesome
like does he think i'm like no i'm just
going to show him costume i'm glad we
announced it and i'm gonna yeah i'll
plan we can coordinate
oh i'm sorry i can do i can plan a
matching outfit or should i just do my
own thing and show up and surprise each
other
let's surprise each other i have
everything i can share you what i'm
gonna wear
i think it'd be fun if we surprise each
other but i know you're going to post it
like a trillion times on every social
media
i'm going to start out subtle maybe our
final the grand finale of the week of
halloween i'll tell you because mine's
actually really good and i feel like
that could be a good duo one
that's amazing you've already planned to
head that far i have me and moses's
costume i have our family costumes
i have my podcast costumes and then i
have my tick tock costume be honest with
me right now yeah
as we end just tell me this how long
and just be totally [ __ ] brutally
honest with me is this relationship with
moses is going to last
like i i like know we're going to get
married wow
cool his mom was very concerned about
that she heard it on the podcast
i'll tell you so his mom well i'll tell
you i'll tell you because
i've been a party i've been in the
middle of all this and i've talked to
you as mom
she's not mad she likes you she's happy
that moses in a relationship
what she's not happy is that he doesn't
talk to her
he doesn't tell her anything mostly just
like that so he so you better [ __ ]
tell him he needs to talk to his mom
more he likes to keep everyone at
distance he doesn't like
well well yeah imagine how his mom feels
i think he had some trauma i don't know
but don't
but don't let him tell you that she
doesn't like you because that's
she doesn't yeah okay he just said that
she can be judgmental
well who what parent can right so i
think he was like more protecting
because i do
you know what i do you score i do do
really good
riley reid taught me how when we did a
collab she went isn't it just peeing
did we talk about this we learned about
it it's peeing two fingers up and press
right here and then release don't show
that don't we can't show that
there's nothing stop stop stop stop
i hope this gets monetized so we get no
checks all right end it thank you guys
we'll see you
next week
[Music]
you